jean-françois vidéo après avoir été le
gourou du baba dans les années 70 c'est
le pape du techno dans les années 80 en
est où maintenant gens refusent de
caricatures tandis ou maintenant voilà
en éclats déjà pas mal et les années
soixante dix on a vu ce qu'elles ont été
années 80 qui nous avait dit qu'elle
serait technologique vigoureuse dès les
années 90 ça va être comment
il faut réfléchir un petit peu là dessus
je pense que
parce qu'un roc j'espère j'espère
qu'elles vont être ni rick way ouverte
et
exploratrice le moba m'énerve parce que
ça t'a énervé oui en même temps moi oui
ça m'énerve parce que en fait des
battles et je n'y ai pas coutume étaient
des feuilles de marijuana en couverture
de thon jaune mais c'était alors je me
trouve encore sur le problème ouais
c'est pas le problème c'est bastos est
dans les normes
ouais ce qui est passée la rumeur s'est
passé dans les moeurs sécu l'euro
d'actuels ou
il faut pas se méprendre dans les années
90 ya quoi dans ton numéro sans nom je
leur aurais bien en parler oui non
mesdames justement ce rapport
on a senti le besoin disons le mur où
son arrivée est bon donc il fallait bien
trouver une solution pour ramasser
la pensée concentré l'époque cela
concentre d'époque tafer deux livres qui
étaient vachement bien c'est déclasser
les années blanches qui ont été à
l'époque le premier s'est plutôt bien
vendu
s est le second en moins bien parce
qu'il était un peu déprimant ouais vous
êtes au courant qu'il disait aussi de
ces mangas blanche ouais mais qu'est ce
que tu fais ce que tu nous prépares en
iran ce moment après tout le moment non
mais ça c'est une forme de bouquins et
demi avec l'ado vous donner tous
actuelle est ce que les soirs de
bouclage et un peu de copier road ou
alors est ce que vous buvez des cafés
que c'est devenu un journal rangés comme
paris match c'est dire que j'aimerais
matthieu anquez de place mais non c'est
reçu que la coupe c'est trop cher pour
ce que c'était mais pas trop longtemps
pour actuelle paraît un peu du tout
parce que c'était on est paysan devrait
pas pour actuelle pour ce que c'est donc
on a emballé tout ça
c'est vrai que
cette commune est quoi ce com - un coup
de rouge et du café world tour numéro je
veux dire tu vas pas indifférent et s'il
veut être dans une boîte j'ai vu bien
sûr il a pour nom des deux on est déjà
dans une boîte dans une toute petite
boîte ici donc non
on a pensé que c'était pas d'une sortie
exceptionnelle qui en sait quelque chose
peut-être qu'ils allaient souvent de
reconstituer à quiberon
donc je suis allée quiberon la seule
voie c'est quand je me suis fait virer
du fmi parce qu'ils font mais là on
parle franchement maintenant pas très
franchement c'est sûr atteindre environ
bien sonné la porte d'autres là dessus
on pense guère montant jamais été trop
d'eau au fond n'a été pour les
expériences et ont continué à être pour
les peines très bien mais
deux expériences ou d'autres d'eau déjà
pris de l'ecstasy par exemple ouais
qu'est cet effet j'étais pas mal village
ça fait une nuit pas mal hein ça fait
n'est pas mais alors serge toubiana jean
françois bizot nous nous expliquer il ya
un instant que certains soirs de
bouclage une époque est désormais
révolue
chez actuelle on prenait certaines
substances pour terminer le bouclage est
ce qu aux cahiers du cinéma ça ça existe
ça brouille et du café y a que du café
du champagne et du champagne
eux c'est du cher d'abord le café et le
champagne après celle ecstasy vous
jamais devant tina tu as déjà ici de
prendre de l'ecstasy non c'était plus
qu'est ce que ça t'a fait il faut que
j'essaye oui on aime tout le monde y
passe
c'est vrai eh oui que ça dure combien de
temps on aime les gens pendant qu'en
même temps pendant toute une vie
pendant toute une vie oui mais ses
formes il aligne et jill d'idiot et
ventura ecstasy watts soit sur fellini a
dit diouf il dit tu as une oeuvre d un
manque d déplace à un coop home and
la chaleur monte carlo bay mais ce but
met à l'honneur à marbella
eh bien pas du tout hamid baamrani
devenu can't get you should know i'm in
as sidra et sur l'extrême personnes il
ne tenait qu'à la vue ou en libye si
vous êtes en train de lancer une mode
encore plus grâce à la télévision d'air
110 ou va relancer l'ecstasy nous on
sait que tournai de manifestants ne t'a
pas un besoin profond un besoin profond
de sa voix à savoir 2 d'amour et vous il
va être qu'elle vous connais quoi quand
vous voulez comme ça va retrouver dans
un état un petit peu différent et bien
je ne peux pas me permettre de la
musique et une paire de sable se
retrouver dans un état différent que la
netteté la précision quand il s'agit de
lire de la musique
oui mais quand vous les mentions du
pardon et les jours au bo lisez pas de
musique et bien je me retrouve dans un
état
si vous voulez d'euphorie parce que la
musique vous donne cet état et vous avez
besoin de rien moi j'ai besoin de la
musique un peu de champagne non ça fait
plus chic des fois mais enfin je dois
dire que peut-être impulsion de paniers
petits et petites scènes souci tout mais
votre copain gauthier vous a jamais
proposé des trucs un peu un peu bizarre
non non il a proposé des joints quand
même sûrement côté non il a proposé
vraiment des délits extraordinaire tenue
formidable oui c'est tout on savait que
jean paul gaultier c'est un vraiment au
couturier de l'an 2000 et qui est
capable de faire des choses classiques
bien entendu est vraiment c'est un
talent très l'armée les sétois de non
non non on va dire que c'est vraiment
dans sa maison il ya une ambiance est
mieux d'être extraordinaire oui très
saine force il exactement
non